[Musique]
c'est pas tellement surprenant on est
dans un monde depuis la révolution
industrielle où finalement on aimait de
plus en plus de gaz à effet de serre
dans l'atmosphère avec le temps sur une
évolution qui n'est pas complètement
linéaire qui est plutôt quasi
exponentielle mais avec des accidents
quand il ya une crise financière quand
il voit là par exemple la crise
sanitaire actuelle factiva
éventuellement au freiner un peu les
émissions mais bon an mal an les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
augmentent
au delà des deux augmentations de
température qui va repartir dans le
monde on ad on a tendance à avoir un
petit plus d'extrême climatiques
notamment des vagues de chaleur donc ça
clairement et puis une deuxième tendance
est aussi un petit peu plus d'extrême
plus vieux c'est à dire d'avoir
effectivement des précipitations un
petit peu plus abondante
[Musique]
donc l'eau dans les yvelines c'est un
vrai et un trait c'est un vrai sujet
donc le fait d'avoir des événements
extrêmes de pluie sa demande de
réfléchir comment on va pouvoir
éventuellement tester toutes les
installations qui ont été faites pour
éviter les inondations
sur la température les yvelines sont pas
trop mal placé au sens où il ya quand
même pas mal de zones boisées et voilà
et aussi de jaune du coup avec de l'eau
donc ça ça a plutôt tendance à atténuer
finalement les vagues de chaleur ces
zones humides où ces zones boisées et
donc c'est des zones à préserver